Boom the oven's ready Chop Chop time to
get bacon daddy want pie
hi Ben Wyatt
this is your lunch
now you should be able to do whatever
you want to with this right
do you want to eat all of it great if
you want to throw it away in the garbage
that's your prerogative but here I come
the government
and I get to take 40 percent of your
lunch
and that Lauren is how taxes work
Fair you're learning no
capital gains tax
you are and this is not a joke
much smarter than most of the people who
work in this building I
mean 32 Mr Swanson Ron
hang on hang on I have something for you
this is a claymore land mine
use that to protect your property
thanks Ron you got it
are you around Swanson oh yeah okay what
exactly did you teach my daughter oh you
must be Mrs Burkes Lauren was supposed
to do a paper on why government matters
this is what she wrote
it doesn't
well said is this a joke no ma'am I
legitimately believe that I'm a
Libertarian oh that's nice well she is a
fourth grader and fourth graders aren't
supposed to have their heads crammed
full of weird ideas they're supposed to
do cute reports and get gold stars I'm
very sorry I was on you ate her lunch
and you gave her a landmine
really well
it seemed appropriate at the time how
Ellis have you put the campaign pictures
up on the website oh yeah
I started doing that
and are you going to finish doing them
later man
I actually think you look really good
except for the
stick up your butt what do you think
Druid was it Nathaniel Ellis man I feel
like these interns do not respect or
like me at all honestly you could loosen
up a bit on the font stuff
and everything in general hey Ellis
elbow El Chupacabra
drinking coffee
[Music]
what oh it's it's a
it's from 40 years ago never mind hey
that was really fun this morning huh
yeah yeah totally
uh
oh wow look at that
did you draw that uh nope I didn't no no
no no it's really good I mean you're
a you're a great artist I can't do this
look
I don't care who you're related to I'm
your boss and you can't keep
disrespecting me like this man I didn't
draw it
your daughter did
what
her
April's not my daughter she's my friend
does everyone think she's my daughter
whatever point is she would never do
that to me
sorry Dad
hey Tom I'm just printing out these
health tips can you grab them for me one
second I'm just looking at some real
estate listings
oh this is perfect for us three bedroom
and oh God less
it has that dream closet you've always
wanted a walk-in closet oh God
what's wrong where'd you go
come back to me stop it don't disappear
on me I Need You Boo
all right uh let's get into it what do
you guys have for help tips and if it's
okay with you Leslie and I are gonna
lead the meeting today because of our
deep spiritual connection
okay
all right is everything okay or okay
everything is great been less than I
just had something magical happen today
at lunch
there are some weird Juju in this room
right now office yoga we do stretches at
our desk or next to our desk or in a
chair always good for you
um
we give everyone pedometers and we have
a contest whoever takes the most steps
wins a prize
anything to get their heart rate up you
know what else gets people's heart rate
up
doing it
talking about sex with my boss
hey what's wrong with you Leslie it's
the workplace it'll be a little bit too
feisty right now you are being a little
bit too much of an ass right now okay
knock it off
I Can't Fight This Feeling Anymore
you and I
we're dating
you should be so lucky Leslie huh
Tom
they should fix that Washington DC has
more dog parks per capita than most
cities Pawnee only has two dog parks
this one and that one which is also an
active parking lot
can you say per capita again I want to
take a picture of you saying per cap I
am so proud of you now stand next to the
screen and think about all the strong
female role models in your life April
came to me with an idea to build a dog
park in Pawnee I recognized her
potential a long time ago and she's
finally living up to it I mean I am so
proud of her I could cry
and here we go one tiny critique if you
do want to be taken seriously you might
want to think a little bit about how you
present yourself oh no this is publicity
for orange new performance art show he's
an animal living on a human farm and you
can go and feed him from your own hand
ugh that's horrifying and so is Oren you
should not be friends with him so after
reviewing all the options I found that
the best location for the dog park is
lot 48.
the one behind Anne's house
no no no no no no no I've been trying to
put a park there for four years I see
the thing is April that lot is mine I've
been doing slow painstaking work so I
don't want to whip out the legalese on
you now but I got dibs what we are going
to do is we're gonna take your
enthusiasm we're gonna bundle it up and
we're gonna find a new place for a dog
park doesn't that sound fun one two
three cheese good girl brought you your
favorite every color of jello
the jello rainbow
thank you oh injured Andy it's kind of
like old times huh
yeah I almost expect you to call me a
cakes
[Laughter]
I'm glad you're okay
oh my God I'm
I'm so sorry I I should not I I'm sorry
that was not
hey April I just heard
are you okay yeah oh my God
listen what I said this afternoon was
stupid
okay I totally want to go out with you
good
I want to be with you
that was nice that yeah
here's just one thing real quick I want
to be totally honestly because I like
you so much but like two minutes ago me
and Ann did KISS
what what here's no no uh it was crazy
she kissed me okay wait where are you
going bye no no no no hey April April
dude don't even think about kissing me
with current and projected deficits we
need to cut expenditures by 32 percent
let's make it an even 40. oh that's not
necessary slash it slash it I am an
official member of a task force
dedicated to slashing the city budget
just saying that gave me a semi
right off the bat we sell City Hall
let somebody turn it into a large gas
station or a TJ Maxx Ron that is a very
creative idea but we don't want to sell
any of our major assets because we don't
want to lose out on any future revenue
streams I hear that don't worry I have
tons more ideas
okay uh
so sorry new ringtone don't cut anything
without me